[Music]
chris is with us in omaha nebraska hi
chris welcome to the ramsey show
hi there how's your guys's day going
better than we deserve sir how can we
help
i was wanting to get some advice from
you um i'm in the military i've been in
about 18 years and i'm getting ready to
retire here in about two years
so with that being said my source of
income is going to be changing a little
bit
and
over the past year my wife and i we've
paid off all of our credit card debt and
our loan debt
and
i think the only thing that we have left
is about 95 000 on a house that i just
bought last year
so with that being said
uh part of the way that i was able to
pay off part of my house it was about
205 thousand i paid 105 000 down payment
uh i was able to save up some money
while i was out on mission
and
uh since my wife and i have gotten
married a few months ago we have not
taken a honeymoon or anything like that
i would want to know if you thought it
was
prudent
to
save up for a honeymoon or some type of
vacation
or if we should try to pay off as much
of the house as humanly possible in the
next two years
and then
go after
a later honeymoon after that is
completed
do you have a fully funded emergency
fund right now
um right now we have about two thousand
dollars saved up my wife just started a
brand new career a few weeks ago
and uh
she and i both of our incomes together
are about a hundred thousand dollars
um
and she's working on saving up so that
way we can have
uh probably a four or five month
emergency fund and then after that we
were wanting to chip away at the
mortgage
um so we're still a couple months two or
three months away from that
uh um
after that i was just wanting to know
what you guys thought of thank you thank
you for your service um
well
what are you talking about spending on
the honeymoon
uh
we're looking at maybe five thousand
dollars and you're gonna do that now or
after the emergency fund is done or when
when are you planning on doing that
after the emergency fund but i wanted to
know what you thought of doing it before
the mortgage i would or if we should i
would you would yeah
and that's that in other words that's by
christmas like this fall you go on your
honeymoon
okay
yeah how old are you
i am 36. okay cool again thank you for
your service i appreciate that um
this is just the uh this is not the
financial advisor this is the old
husband that's been married 40 years um
it's a really good investment to do this
honeymoon thing
[Laughter]
and it sounds like y'all have been
working really hard the fact that you've
put down such a big down payment you've
paid off all your debts you've been
doing a lot of things right and really
committed to it so it's like once you
hit baby steps four through six you know
you're still working hard you're still
following the process but you can
breathe a little bit more you can take
that honeymoon go on a vacation exactly
right after you've gotten baby step
three in place you're dead free accept
the house you have the emergency fund
four five and six just like you just
said is where you save up and do some
other stuff
uh and that means like that's where you
buy a couch or you go on a vacation
or you pay cash for an upgrade and car
or whatever it is you're gonna do all of
that after between baby step three while
you're doing
four five and six and what that means is
it's going to reduce every time you do
one of those consumption things that you
do need to do at that stage
um it's going to reduce the speed at
which you pay off your mortgage and so
we we teach you to be intense baby steps
one through three getting out of debt
and having the emergency fund nothing
happens there
no vacation no eating out beans and rice
rice and beans and once you move past
your emergency fund being in place you
move from intense to intentional
and that's what we're saying here now
we're intentional and that's exactly the
way chris was asking the question so
he's ahead of the game and i love like
the fact that he is so motivated to pay
off the house like don't lose that
motivation we're not saying that but you
can take a honeymoon breathe a little
bit but definitely keeping that
intentionality is awesome